final start for dustin may is a 22 year
old who celebrate his birthday on sunday
seven starts so far two runs or fewer in
all seven
rymel hitting at 303
no homers has 10 rbis
and this ball is lifted to pretty deep
right this is going to get on out home
run what a start rymel tapia his first
of the year could not come in a better
locale home of the 2-2
gets him looking a fast ball to the
knees for the first down but no one from
may
flips it into
backs out of the infield short right
bellinger's back to catch it two way
on a 1-2 pitch he stays down with a fast
ball and gets a swing and a miss for
strike three antonio senzatella ready to
go he's coming off a great performance
looking for his fourth victory are they
good hitters yeah but it's not it's not
like here's a chance for two there's one
on the first double play good job by
senza to get over there two gone for
muncie
muncie turns on a ball smashes it to
right blackman's back and the game is
tied
max muncie is solo home run and both
teams are the home run here in the first
go back in square one just like that
3-2 on the ground into the shift
trevor's got it
it retires the side each team with a
home run in the first a little bit
taller and they found that they liked it
that's a swing and a miss strike three
blackman the first out of the four
another one two from dustin may an
elevated fastball at 100 and no catching
up to that fifth inning
we're tied at one in los angeles
this ball is lifted high and deep right
field take a good look
you won't see it for long sam hilliard
is struck again against the dodgers and
against dustin may
2-1
[Applause]
colorado bounce to third muncie go to
second one lux with a throw on target
this time a double play gavin lux with
plenty of time on the turn but he
doesn't like to do many things slow over
there around the bag so this quick
release beats arenado by a mile
not even in the picture
put away
lead off double mookie bets in the time
running scoring position sends a tele
deals and seeger jams one through the
left side base head here comes mookie
betts to tie the game
corey seeger with an rbi single then
it's 2-2
is one-o
swatted to right center field
he's got it
seeger tags and advances they're at the
corners with two out
a two out chance for peterson
with an o for two so far tonight over
his last 14. another 3-2 swang and a
miss he threw the high cheese by him
michael gibbons keeps this game tied
first for will smith oh for two tonight
there he goes here it comes smith hits a
ball in the air to left center field
back towards the wall it is gone
two-run home run will smith
and the dodgers take the lead here in
the seventh
gibbons leaves the game chased from the
game on a home run from smith still
nobody out gavin lux is second 4-2
dodgers seventh inning
bets lifts one to left center field
hillyard angling back try the track he's
got it
luck's tagging from second he's in the
third safely
fly to center field
sizes it up he's under it to make the
catch here comes locks throw to the
plate is up the first base side and a
sacrifice fly for corey seeger to make
it 5-2 tripping in his second run
tonight
runner at first nobody out one-two pitch
baltimore chop right side in a tough
spot bellinger fields race to the bag
won by granderol
good attempt by tapia bellinger and
greta all both nice plays to get him up
the second goes fuentes 2-2 pitch to
trevor story
lofted to left-center field
really high not that deep play pollock's
got it two out
he got away with one right there so
pilar who had one of the biggest hits in
wednesday afternoon's comeback trying to
deliver here and drive to left field
going back to the wall and it is gone
touch them all time for kevin pallar
the grand tour
and the rockies are back in the lead
six to five
pollock to the plate representing the go
ahead run he's one for three
cracks one in the air right center field
indeed pilar's back on it at the wall it
is gone
and pollock puts them right back in
front
opposite field two-run home run and it
flips again
peterson now high drive to right jack
peterson and aj pollock back to back
here in the a so right after kevin palar
hits a grand slam dodgers go single
homer homer
bets it's a high fly ball to left center
field back goes
he's out of room with another home run
five tonight for the dodgers who have
thrown a late party here to steal things
from colorado
[Applause]
on the hands and this should do it
taylor the call and the catch and the
dodgers take another tonight getting
eight runs over their final two at bats